the change of strategy for president
biden as he works with fellow democrats
holding up two key pieces of his
domestic agenda friday the president met
with democratic house members on capitol
hill in an effort to win support and
encourage compromise for his
infrastructure plan and his massive
social programs initiative the bottom
line the president will need more time
to push those bills across the finish
line christina raffini has the latest
from the white house christina good
morning
good morning dana that's right speaker
of the house nancy pelosi had promised
moderates a vote on that infrastructure
bill but when progressives threatened to
tank the measure those plans fell apart
after an in-person visit from president
biden we're going to get it done some
progressive democrats say they may be
willing to compromise on their proposed
3.5 trillion dollar spending plan if we
are going to think about anything less
than the number what we would rather do
is get as many things in
as possible maybe
not everything can be funded for 10
years maybe it's going to be a lesser
period of time democratic infighting
over the size and scope of the bill is
putting the president's domestic agenda
at risk it doesn't matter whether it's
in six minutes six days or six weeks
we're going to get it done and has twice
delayed a house vote on the 1.2 trillion
dollar bipartisan infrastructure bill
there is a little bit of distrust
among the
progressives and the moderates and we're
trying to we're trying to figure out a
process how do we get there how do we
land this plane
but while warring factions fixate on the
spending measure are we going to live
deliver universal pre-k to this country
or not are we going to expand health
care to our seniors and include vision
and dental or not
the stalled infrastructure plan has
caused a lapse in funding for certain
highway and transit programs
and the furlough of workers there are 4
000 lives and families too that might be
furloughed because of us i mean come on
now yesterday the house did approve a
30-day funding measure for the
department of transportation to help
mitigate some of those furloughs that
measure will go to the senate this
afternoon michelle
all right christina thank you